miles huyendo de Rusia los aeropuertos y
vías terrestres de los países más
cercanos a Rusia reportaron un
incremento en la llegada de ciudadanos
rusos luego del anuncio del presidente
Vladimir Putin en el que convoca a una
movilización parcial de reservistas Para
apoyar su llamada operación especial en
Ucrania los países vecinos Armenia
Turquía azerbaiyán y Serbia han dicho
que Los tiquetes desde Rusia se han
agotado y no cesan las largas filas en
las fronteras de Rusia con Georgia
Finlandia kazajistán y mongolia
seguiré la situación creo que en El
Siglo 21 participar en la guerra es un
error Así que estaré atento a la
situación
no puedo decir que tenga pánico me
Estaba preparando para este escenario
actúe con bastante rapidez y crucé la
frontera con normalidad
Finlandia es el único miembro de la
Unión Europea fronterizo con Rusia que
permite el paso de ciudadanos rusos con
visas schengen luego de que a principios
de septiembre Polonia y los tres países
bálticos decidieran impedir la entrada
de ciudadanos rusos en la mayoría de los
casos desde el inicio de la guerra el
país nórdico ha incrementado su
recepción de extranjeros Pero según una
encuesta del diario IL tasanomat
alrededor del 70% de los finlandeses
quieren que se acabe la emisión de visas
a turistas rusos mientras Alemania Busca
liderar la política de puertas abiertas
para lo que ha llamado desertores rusos
según el kremlin El Éxodo es exagerado
la información sobre los aeropuertos y
demás es muy exagerada se exageró mucho
hay mucha información falsa sobre esto
Tenemos que tener mucho cuidado con esto
para no ser Víctimas de información
falsa sobre este asunto
en redes sociales se han compartido
consejos sobre cómo Y a cuáles países se
puede huir luego de que varios países de
Europa restringieran la emisión de visas
a los rusos como sanciona Moscú por la
invasión de Ucrania